Stephen Curry of the Golden State
Warriors uh let go here Steph uh once
again an absolute joy to watch you play
we saw you ripping your jersey on
Saturday tonight as I've been saying all
show 378 and S it's just another process
how how are we feeling as the leader of
this group as we get closer to the
all-star
break it's been a emotional ride for you
know our whole team this whole year uh
we we talked about some self-inflicted
wounds we've had you know some games
that we should have won you know some
things off the court and our in our
family uh you know dealing with that and
obviously like you know whatever we were
five games under 500 until theight like
there's always there's a sense of
desperation for us so I mean The Vibes
are as positive as they can be um it's
just a matter for us to have a night
like tonight where you just get a win to
get over the hump and you know be able
to come back to the locker room and have
something to smile about and that
hopefully will be contagious as we go on
the road uh for this next trip Steph VC
here uh I know you're the face and
you're expected to do so much but how
important uh is it that you have Wiggins
kaminga and Draymond you know playing
like they're playing right now to give
you some other support yes you had a big
night but there are other guys that
played well tonight to make the game
easier for you to help your team win and
to to boost confidence moving forward
everybody has to be aggressive you know
in this league it's it's really hard for
you know any one person I don't care who
you are to you know you can impact the
game you can have your numbers and all
that but you know teams make adjustments
they try to make it hard on you and
everybody you know in our offense has to
be aggressive to score to create um
we're starting to understand the
pictures a little bit more in terms of
how guys how teams are guarding us as a
fiveman unit and for wigs JK to be as
aggressive as they were tonight Draymond
knocking down threes you know BP being
able to probe a little bit
uh it it matters and obviously without
clay tonight too that's a lot of
shooting that you're missing so we
needed that aggressiveness Steph what's
up is Jamal uh just want to give you a
props as always for me every kid around
the world is trying to play like you
they're trying to mimic you what did
your imagination come from how did you
start playing like this how do you
continue to push the envelope of how you
play what excites you to keep keep going
and keep that imagination and creativity
going I mean y'all all all three y know
how much you know you love playing this
game so anytime I step out of here it's
it's my happy place and you know that
that Joy has to be there uh you know I
did Rip a jersey and frustration but the
joy of playing the game is is always
there uh I don't know where the
imagination creativity come from
probably was playing uh VC in 101 when I
was 10 up up at the Air Canada Center
yeah watching that watching that man so
I've been inspired by so many people
yourself included um but it I don't want
I don't want this to end anytime soon
Steph Candace Parker here um Joy you
talk about that all the time um in wins
and in losses what can you say to the
young basketball players out there about
getting through the ups and downs and
the slumps and whether it's shooting
whether it's the team not winning like
how do you as the face of this franchise
push this franchise forward when things
aren't going
right when times are hard you have to
just stick to and and commit to the
process that you've uh developed over
time that you know that that's where the
preparation you know develops confidence
so everybody is impacted by the results
you know win or losses in terms of your
emotions you try to stay as even keill
as possible but you know it's all about
the process like you know how much you
know work that you put in on your body
on your mind on your skill set and
whether you're you know shooting the
ball horribly like you're having a slump
or whether you're losing games that
process will hopefully get you out of it
um and that's the only thing that you
can kind of rely on so you know control
the controllables as much as you can can
and and I think the attitude is the you
know first and foremost in that respect
all right Steph last one before we go
for the first time ever it looks like
we're going to have an NBA versus WNBA
three-point challenge unesc dropped 37
and now the stage is set we're going to
see this on Allstar
Weekend how we feeling about this what's
the preparation going into it what
should we
expect I I think this is like the
coolest thing ever know uh you know she
kind of broke the Airways when she uh I
think she only missed two or something
like that in 27 yeah and uh I don't know
I was on some golf course somewhere and
my phone was blowing up saying uh you
know what's to bringa done so I think
the fact that we can you know join
forces you know put her front and center
at NBA Allstar Weekend you know I've
done a Three-Point Contest plenty of
times I've won it twice she's got the
record uh she even stepped it up she
said she going to shoot from the NBA
three-point line so uh I love the
confidence I love the competition it's a
it's a new new format on that stage you
know obviously I'm I'm coming to win so
I know she is too so it's it's it's
going to be great I think the fans will
love it Stephen Curry another incredible
performance thank you so much man
congrats appreciate yall thank
you